Hey I died fireman the original
experiment
Mary Jane case I don't mean sorry good
luck dragon more evolution in the
problem they talk about hand farting and
forget it the guys suck hi I saw Sweeney
tottenham mind right yeah I just saw a
night like this you know it was terrible
it's all I can say for now so I don't
waste your time
scream it opening scene what you very
more as character is video with the
phone on with those face there's that
stupid thing where that they have her
with the I'm sorry I wasted your time
goodbye oh my god I love this guy okay I
don't know what to say I was calling you
about something
hold on I really am just hold on
there
I guess I'll call you back a trick
[Music]